- [Mark] So Soul Brother,
how long have you been
down here on Skid Row?
- Must be like 9,000 years, man.
(men laughing)
Yeah.
- Feels like it.
- Yeah, man, for real, man.
It's been a while, man.
- [Mark] And your typical
day dealing is like,
you're working at night,
you're working during the day?
All day, all night?
- I put it to you like this.
When duty calls, you know,
then that's when it's done.
- [Mark] So you're just
sleeping when you can?
- Not necessarily.
I do my best to get my
sleep, but you know,
I'm like an advocate for
the people, you know?
I like helping the people, you know?
I look at them and I understand, you know,
some of the things that the
people go through, you know?
Ask me another question.
- Yeah.
Now do you, I mean, when you see
some of the people that
are severely addicted,
do you feel in any way
responsible on your end
for putting them in that situation,
or are you just solving a problem?
- Well, this is not my problem.
It's not my mind frame.
It's they mind frame.
It's something that
they're going to do whether
I do this or that, whether
anyone does this or that.
Whether it be the cops, you know,
whether it be an informant,
whether it be whoever
it might be, you know,
whether they find it,
it's their personality.
It's their character.
It's what's in them, it's in their DNA.
It has nothing to do with what I do.
It's not like, you know,
we're putting a gun
to someone's face and saying,
"Here, take this," you know
because I'm not trying to say take this.
I'm not trying to say
here, Imma give you this.
I'm not trying to say I'll
do anything, you know?
I'm not trying to say
that come to me, you know,
and I'll help you to freedom,
you know, or free your mind.
A person can hold themselves in bondage,
you know, hold themselves hostage.
- [Mark] On a good night
you would make what?
- Doing that probably, shit...
$10,000 or something like that, just-
- Wow.
- Yeah, on a typical night
because it comes fast like that.
It would be all the same.
- Yeah.
And what were you selling?
- I was selling crack.
- Crack?
- Yeah.
- Only crack?
- [Soul Brother] Well, I sold crack,
and I had what I called the
best little whorehouse in Texas,
you know what I mean?
People would come in
and they appreciate it
because there would be some security
if you wanted to go to the boom boom room.
The boom boom room is get
your fucking, your sucking on
and doing whatever it is
that you feel is necessary
to make you happy, you know?
Someone wanted to escape, I'm like, well,
it's a great escape right here, you know?
You can come in and be
part of my friendship.
We gonna be friends, we be
friends, friends, friends.
(Mark laughing)
- [Mark] And you had lots
of regular customers,
or people just know?
- [Soul Brother] Yeah, you know,
I had this lawyer dude, man.
He would come, in a week's
time, he spent $400, man.
$400 every week, that's like
the least that he would spend.
And yeah, there was regular customers
because they trusted me
that I would protect them,
that I would help them.
They trusted that I would
always lead them the right way
'cause I never would try
and convince a person
to buy something that they
already wanted to buy, you know?
If that's what they're doing,
then that's what they're doing, you know?
It's on them, you know.
- [Mark] Do you use it often?
- I have from time to time, you know.
I've entertained people 'cause you know,
there's a lot of women, they always say,
"Hey, try this and do this
because it makes your dick hard,"
and like there's nothing
wrong with my yang, you know.
That motherfucker get hard
automatically and shit.
I don't need no rub, no,
what's that stuff they do?
Whatever I don't need no-
They got something they
call a motherfucking
turkey baster and shit.
I said you don't gotta put
no turkey baster in my ass
and shit to make my dick hard.
Motherfucker going to get hard
by looking at you when you fine and shit.
And sometimes, you know, when people think
that I'm the cop selling
something to them.
I yeah, of course, I do it.
- [Mark] So you, you've
tried stuff, you don't.
- I don't like cling to
it because then I'll be
where I don't wanna be, you know.
And of course, I've been
there and done that.
There's been a lot of ups
and downs in life, you know,
and you gotta grab the bull
by the horns, you know?
And then again, you know,
addiction is another form
of holding yourself hostage, you know
because it's only what
we create in our mind.
Our mind tells us that we
have to go and go do this.
Our mind tells us that only
way out of the institute is.
Our mind tells us that we have to be free,
and so in order to be
free, I escape like whoosh,
going to another realm.
We're going to a whole
'nother matrix so to speak.
- [Mark] You been to prison?
- Yeah I've been to prison.
- How many times?
- Four times.
- Four times?
- Yeah.
- For possession?
- For various things,
different things and shit.
You know, they always, you know,
sometimes the cops, they set
your ass up on some sell shit.
They do some shit, you know, like man,
I didn't do that shit, man
because they can't catch you-catch you.
They gonna catch you.
I had a cop tell me this one time.
He ran up on me, boom, I
smashed the pipe I had, shhhh,
and you know, he didn't see-
He didn't see no drugs or nothing.
He said, "You're still going to jail, man.
"There's no matter what you
do, you're going to jail.
"I don't care. You're
just going to go to jail.
"You know what I mean?
"We'll work those things
out once we get there."
Ain't that some fucked up shit?
- [Mark] He just knew what
he knew and wanted you-
- Well, you know, if a cop can conspire
from a conspiracy theory
or whatever the hell
you wanna call it, man,
then so be it, you know.
Sometimes if he believes in his mind,
he or she believes in their mind, that
if they just get what
they know is happening
because it's going on
gut instinct, you know
but that's what fuck their
ass up too, you know.
If they just go by that, you know,
then hopefully when I get there,
then I'll get somebody else, you know,
get somebody else, you
know 'cause one time,
they did this shit, too,
right on this street right here, man.
They use the same case of
cigarettes to bust like 15 people
and even wrote it in the police report,
and that shit kept going to court, man.
Does that make sense?
- So they're setting 'em up?
- Yeah, I mean, it's,
it's a setup, man.
It's fucked up shit.
By wanting to be what they call
true to the game, you know.
You have to be true all the way around.
You can't just be true to what you want.
You can't just be true to
just helping you and yours.
If you're gonna be true to the game,
you gotta really be in
the game because the game,
it's gonna come back
and bite you in the ass
one way or the other 'cause
in everything you do,
you gotta do it the right way, you know.
If you're a bank robber,
there's only one way rob the motherfucker.
It ain't trying to pick
up all the dollars.
You grabbing' what you know you're gonna
go in there and get.
You're not trying to do
some stupid ass shit.
You not gonna take a broad
that makes $5,000 a night
versus one that makes $50 a night
walking' the damn streets
because you like the way
she looks better than you like this one.
That's not gonna work. That's
not the right way to do that.
So you gotta, you know, take
that shit and balance it out.
You gotta be balanced the right way, man.
- [Mark] What age were
you when you started
selling for the first time?
- Shit I was probably, you
know when I was younger,
I was about seven or eight,
and I didn't know exactly
what I was doing and shit,
but I'm running' this shit up
and down the damn street, man,
and I didn't know what
the fuck I was doing
because give a kid twenty dollars,
that's a lot of Now and Laters man,
and they sold the big pack of
Now and Laters then, you know.
- Of what?
- Now and Laters.
- Now and Laters?
- Now and Laters
they call them, but sometimes
black people say "nowalaters."
We forget about the Now and the Later,
but the candy is called
Now and Laters, you know,
so we say "nowalaters," sound
like "nowalaters", yeah,
but that was a lot of
money to a kid, you know.
You a kid, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11,
and somebody hand you $20.
Man, you know how much
candy you can buy, man?
You can buy a whole lot of candy, dude.
You can do a whole lot of everything, man.
- [Mark] That's right, that's
a lot of money to a kid.
- I used to love having
my little candy store
because they got all people
coming to me and stuff
and doing this and doing that, you know.
Always being in my mind, you know,
and that was a pretty cool feeling,
a pretty cool sensation and all, man.
But running numbers, doing little bookies
and all that type of stuff, man, you know,
and I didn't know I was giving pills
to them nurse ladies and stuff like that.
I didn't know that.
I just thought I was just
handing Auntie Cookie a bag
'cause everybody Auntie
Cookie, Auntie Sandra,
Auntie somebody and shit, you know.
It's just Auntie Fifi, auntie
whoever the hell it is,
or uncle motherfucking uncle, you know.
That's what that is, man.
And I didn't know that's
what I was doing, you know,
but it was cool little change
because you know you have to do something.
When you want some new shoes,
you gotta do something.
When you want new everything, you know,
and you you refuse to lose,
you refuse to be held down
by what's holding you down,
you know, by what we see
'cause a little kid
don't know nothing but-
- [Mark] When you were young, that age,
what options did you see
for yourself in life?
Did you see, like, selling
drugs was one option?
Yeah, stealing stuff was another.
Did you have like college,
or did you see like friends
of yours going off to college?
- Now, that shit is the
furthest thing from your mind
to be honest with you, man,
and you know when a motherfucker
say some shit like that,
you know, I'm gonna go to college.
Not saying that a kid is dumb
because children are very incredible.
They have a very-
- [Mark] The environment
that they're raised in
dictates a lot of what their future holds.
- I know because, see,
and I ponder on this,
and I always consider
how I choose to select
the right choice of words when
I'm talking to young people
because I know when I was younger,
when Reagan became president
and he got shot that time,
the principal had asked me, he said,
"What do you think about
our president being shot,"
and I said that motherfucker
got what he deserved,
but that's only because
I heard grownups say that
'cause I ain't know no damn Reagan
from whoever the hell he was and shit.
You get where I'm coming from?
Politics didn't mean nothing to me.
I'm a kid.
- Yeah.
- You know I'm 11, 12 years old, so-
- [Mark] You're just
repeating what you heard.
- Yeah, you dig what I mean?
I don't know nothing about
that, but I'm like, yeah,
he got what he deserved, old
white cracker and all this.
I don't know no damn better
'cause a child is not born prejudiced.
A child is taught to be prejudiced.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- You cannot grow coming out of the womb,
and you know, "Nigger,"
you can't. (laughs)
- [Mark] You learn that.
- That's all that is, man.
That's all that is, man.
- [Mark] Where do you like to
see yourself in five years?
- In five years...
Owning Soul Brother's Airlines.
(Mark laughing)
For real though, man.
You know, when I did sell a lot of drugs,
I invested in a lot of houses
and different things like this,
but I didn't know this cat
was followed by the feds.
So I'm like giving him all
my money and stuff, you know,
giving him money like, oh cool
'cause you know, I do a little
painting, a little drywall,
a little of this and a
little bit of that, you know.
You got a hole in the wall
or house needs a couple of walls,
I can put them in no time flat, you know,
but doing all that broker
stuff and everything like that.
I didn't know anything about
that at the time, you know,
and I just said okay, this
guy has got his office.
He got a good setup.
It was just a setup, you know,
but lucky I wasn't tied to it, you know,
'cause I miss my 4,000
square foot house that I had,
you know, and the motherfuckers came
and took it from me and shit.
I miss that motherfucker like
a motherfucker, you know.
- Do you have family?
- I have family, man.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- Spread all over the world, man.
- [Mark] How many kids?
- Seven.
- Seven kids?
- Yeah.
I say two of them, I don't know,
but then they hold them up to me,
so I can't say nothing else.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(men laughing)
Did you experiment with selling
some of the other drugs
that are on street?
There's heroin, there's crystal meth.
- Yeah, when I was selling,
like I was telling you,
selling drugs and fifty
dollars was the last I sold,
I sold chunks of heroin
and shit, you know,
and friends of mine, they
would tell me like, man,
you need to be more
sensitive to the situation
and circumstance of a heroin addict.
I had this chick, pretty ass bitch, man.
Prettiest thing in the world.
Mexican chick, man.
I mean that broad was like, damn, man.
It's just, every time you see her,
the whole world would
stop, literally, for real,
and she knew this, but
it was just something
about me and myself, you know,
that made her take a liking to me, man,
and every time she would
take her shot of heroin,
she gotta sit like right here on my knee,
like busting a nut and shit.
She just had to like squirm,
and then a little
perspiration would come on.
I'm like, damn, man,
that shit turned me the
fuck on like that, man.
And what I was doing while
I was selling that shit,
I didn't have it for her at the time
because I didn't know in my mind
that I'm supposed to keep it for her
to keep her around me and shit, you know.
I'm thinking just I'm keeping her around
because I'm me, you know?
And so one day, she needed that shit,
and I'm like it was nowhere to be found,
and I was money and shit like here,
and she's threw it back, and she said,
"That shit is not gonna
help me right now."
I'm like, what the fuck
wrong with you bitch?
- [Mark] So she was coming to see you,
and you end up not having what she needed?
- Right because I don't
know I'm supposed to
keep that shit all the
time, all the damned time.
(speakers drowning one another out)
I don't know that okay, she's
about to run out and shit,
you know, and so I better go
order some more shit or whatever.
I don't care if I don't
have it for two days.
It's not my problem and
shit, you know what I mean,
but that's the way that I thought.
So she come in and talking to me.
I'm like well damn, I
don't got none, here,
and I just, it wasn't a thought
of what it was in my pocket.
I'm like here, go get it and
shit, you know what I mean,
'cause I enjoyed having her around
because she was that type of female,
and she took that shit
and threw that shit back.
I'm like bitch, what the
fuck's wrong with you?
'Cause I'm saying in my mind, you know,
this is a lot of motherfucking money
that I just gave you right now and shit,
so you go, in other words,
go buy all the shit you need
and bring your ass back
because that's just
where my mind is and shit,
and she threw that shit back, and that,
that gave me a motherfucking light bulb
so damn bright in my head, you know,
like what the fuck is
going on in the world, man?
- [Mark] Lots of crazy
stuff here on Skid Row.
- [Soul Brother] You know, Skid
Row is what we make it, man.
You know, it's no rules, laws,
or regulations, you know.
It's like this, you know.
Some people have come
to, how can I say this?
Come to find Neverland,
but they never, never land.
They just keeping staying high.
They wanna land but.